now who's ready to talk murder we have
to wake up to murders every morning
they're talking about the serial killer
that's like basically in our backyard it
is so exciting
L.A it's brutal especially when you're
pushing 50. bartenders into you that's
gonna be bartender's dad did anyone
catch my favorite murder no spoilers
what do you even know about this guy
should I use protection or should he
just pull out you know if I end up on
Dateline I can leave a massive DNA Trail
for you True Crime weirdos
can't pay any of our bills you just lost
your job we have a baby on the way so
tell me how are we going to get by
she is the victim of the West Side
Ripper it's him
I know my Killers but if we make a
podcast about this together we could
bring them in on it bring the killer in
on what the podcast we force them to do
it oh my God this is gonna change our
lives
no one ever went broke betting on
America's obsession with murder he'll
never hurt anyone ever again or we go to
the cops let's do this babe you're so
hot it's bad for the baby says actually
pull my hair come on baby
are you in danger you really think he's
gonna kill us
what do you know about the west side rip
We Are In Too Deep this sit we're gonna
have a baby in jail
what's going to do next no I lied no I'm
hiding something I love him are you
crazy
[Applause]
you want to come visit me in San Quentin
Midnight Express me under the table what
is that you don't look like you're
sleeping I don't do that come on bad
behave here
[Music]